how's it going everybody it's Warren and
this morning we were treated to an
awesome surprise by Marvel Studios and
the Russo brothers we got the second
official trailer for Avengers endgame
and with the trailer we got a ton of new
footage and what seems like a lot of new
information about the movie I've already
done one breakdown this morning if you
want to check that out I'll link it up
above as well as put it in the
description and at the end of this video
but in this video I want to talk about
something very specific that I think we
see in this New Avengers in-game trailer
and that is the Avengers fighting Thanos
there are a lot of scenes in this
trailer that I think are the Avengers
fighting Thanos very early on in the
movie and in this video I'll break it
all down for you and tie it to some of
the leaks that we've gotten over the
past couple of weeks and the footage
that was shown at the Disney
shareholders meeting quick reminder
about my giveaway I'm giving away five
imax tickets if you'd like to enter for
your chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain so with this new Avengers
in-game trailer keep in mind what the
president of Marvel Studios Kevin Feige
said about the footage that's in it he
said most of the footage in the trailer
will be from the first 15 to 20 minutes
of the movie and in this trailer I think
that is mostly accurate there are a lot
of scenes that I actually think are the
Avengers fighting Thanos there's a plot
leaked out there that says the first
plan of the Avengers is to go and fight
Thanos this ties in to the very last
scene of the trailer with Captain Marvel
and Thor we actually got a leaked
description of this scene a few days ago
from a Disney shareholder Disney had a
shareholders meeting where they showed
footage for Avengers in game and one of
the shareholders went online and
described what he saw and he described
to the T this very last scene that we
see in the trailer with Thor and Captain
Marvel talking Thor grabs his axe and
says I like this one which means that he
was telling the truth in his description
leek was real but they didn't show all
of the scene in this trailer they just
showed the end I like this one
the full scene is about going and
finding Thanos nebula and Tony are back
on earth and nebula says that she knows
where Thanos is rocket also says that
when Thanos snapped it was the biggest
energy surge he'd ever seen and he can
still trace that surge to a distant
planet and that's where famous is at
this point Captain Marvel is already
there and she's telling the rest of the
Avengers that they have to go right now
and fight Thanos the Avengers start
talking to each other and then Bruce
Banner asked what kind of guarantee they
have that they could actually defeat
Thanos this time in which Captain Marvel
says this time you have me and right
after this happens Thor gets up goes in
front of Captain Marvel call
Stormbreaker to his hand and says I like
this one which we just saw in the second
trailer so in this scene in the
beginning of the movie The Avengers are
talking about a plan to go in find
Thanos and fight him and I think that's
exactly what they do and they lose I
think this happens very early on in the
movie because I don't think ant-man is
there yet so they wouldn't know about
the quantum realm or time travel plus
Thor was there when Thanos snapped he
saw that the Infinity Gauntlet was
damaged and he saw that Thanos was
damaged as well so Thor knows that the
gauntlet is damaged he tells the rest of
the Avengers plus they have Captain
Marvel now and the element of surprise
so their first plan would be to take the
benitar which is now back and rocket
could repair very easily and go to
Thanos and fight him this would explain
some of the battle scenes that we see in
this trailer because again Kevin Feige
said that the footage in the trailers
will most likely only be from the first
15 to 20 minutes of the movie this would
explain why we see battle scenes we see
war machine and rocket in the middle of
a battle we see Thor looking like he's
about to prepare for battle we have
nebula and what looks to be the middle
of a huge battle and she's screaming and
who else would she be screaming at this
super hateful scream
besides Thanos she hates Thanos her sole
purpose before was to kill thanos for
everything that he's done to her and now
he's killed her sister Gamora and half
of the universe so in the middle of a
huge battle I can't imagine nebula
screaming at anybody else besides Thanos
and then we have Captain America
strapping his shield on again in the
middle of the battle looks like he's
getting his butt kicked and in this
battle he's going to be with the other
Avengers and who could defeat all of the
Avengers so easily besides Thanos even
if the Infinity Gauntlet is broken and
doesn't work and he can't restore it
with the time stone for whatever reason
he's strong enough to use the Infinity
stones by themselves we've seen him hold
the Infinity stones with his bare hands
in infinity war so we know he's
immensely powerful so I think the
Avengers go and fight him and they fail
and they end up returning to earth
somehow there's a plot leaked out there
that says the Avengers go to Fanus they
fight him he defeats them and he feels
pity for them so he sends them back to
earth and that could very well happen
because we've learned from the Russo
brothers that Thanos never intentionally
killed anybody unless he thought they
were a threat to his plan it's very
clear that the Avengers are not a threat
to his plan they tried to stop him once
they failed they try to stop him again
they fail again so he clearly would not
see them as a threat and he did show
signs of sympathy in Avengers infinity
war so he very well could take pity on
them so I think they end up back on
earth they don't know what to do and
some time passes by this would explain
why black widows hair is blonde in some
scenes and it's red and the others it
would also explain why there are missing
person posters that ant-man is looking
at it would explain why there is a where
do we go now that they're gone poster
why there are support groups for people
who have lost others to the snap so this
would explain why there is a time lapse
and why there is some fighting at the
beginning of the movie and then after
some time has passed ant-man finally
gets out of the quantum realm he doesn't
find Hank Janet or hope when he gets out
he goes home doesn't find his daughter
doesn't find Louise doesn't find anybody
that he knows so he goes to the Avengers
headquarters they tell him what happened
and he tells them how he was stuck
inside of a quantum realm and discovered
a time vortex this is where the new plan
of time-travel comes into play to stop
Thanos and that's when we see the
Avengers and they're all white quantum
realm suits and that's how the rest of
the movie plays out the Avengers going
back in time to stop Thanos this is what
I think we're going to see in the
beginning of Avengers in game and what I
think we're seeing some of in this new
trailer with all these scenes where it
looks like the Avengers are in battle it
ties in directly with some footage that
we've seen in this new trailer and some
legitimate plot leaks that we've heard
as well
so I think in the beginning of Avengers
in game we'll see The Avengers go and
find Thanos fight him and lose so let me
know what you think about
this and the comments down below do you
think this is how it will play out or do
you think something else let me know and
again don't forget to subscribe comment
down below and like the video so you can
enter the giveaway and stay up to date
on everything relating to Avengers in
game and Marvel as always thank you all
so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you